you've written
I think 81 books okay and you even made
a romantic spoken word album you've made
several of them romantic spoken word
albums were these intended to sort of
get people maybe they put this album on
it gets them feeling a little sexy that
is that we use for one of these albums
sexual energy is a form of spiritual
energy there is nothing that is not
creative that doesn't have those two
energies spiritual and sexual so of
course the album's are meant to evoke
the experience of love whether it's love
for your spouse for your lover for a
guard for your siblings love is the
highest intelligence in the universe and
when you're in love no matter what it is
even science or philosophy then love
makes you want to do magnificent things
people who are in love can do
extraordinary things I bring this up
because I watched one of these in a
YouTube video and I watched one of these
it's your spoken word album and it's
been put to these images and I found it
very erotic let's take a look
[Music]
a lover knows only humility he has no
choice he steals into your alley at
night he has no choice he longs to kiss
every lock of your hair
don't fret he has no choice
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Applause]
you